Christianity like I'm not against
Christianity but oh my gosh I'm so
offended I haven't even said anything oh
why are you bringing so much hate I
haven't even said anything why are you
lying I am so upset you're bringing so
much hate oh ha you're so funny what's
your question okay you guys believe in
the Trinity right yes all right so when
in the Bible doesn't mention the Trinity
you are you a Muslim by the way yeah
yeah I'm Muslim all right do you believe
in t what is that dang what is that I I
got to spend time teaching Islam to
Muslims a lot it's okay so I'm not I'm
not I'm not out of because like I don't
know I don't understand Arabic okay all
right fair enough fair enough so
basically Ted it's this is what the word
is called it's it's referring to it's
referring to Allah's Oneness and
uniqueness okay all right so the Muslims
call this
Ted now the worded is nowhere in the
Quran but yet it is an essential belief
system within
Islam says the Muslims C stop lying you
literally ran away stop lying in the
comments I can see that cop you KN you
ran away Copic yeah exactly
sh yeah all yeah soed is is an essential
Concept in Islam however well you know
that you came to the right place I you
know I I don't understand you why are
you like making like stuff up what do
you mean making stuff up are you are you
near a computer no I swear I'm not what
the hell no I want you to be because you
we're in the we're in the age of
information so I need you to get a
computer or even go on your phone really
quick just go on your phone really quick
and put in to but in what is Ted t a
w i all right hold up T A whid
toheed put in what is toheed hey listen
that concept is literally written in the
Quran it says like it says God is like
one only mhm but the word is not there
right how are you proving it wrong I
don't understand no I'm Pro I'm showing
you something that just because the word
is not in the Quran doesn't mean the
concept is not there in the Quran you
understand what I'm saying the concept
of even though I would I would challenge
this but the concept of is in the Quran
even though the word is not there it's
the same thing with the Trinity the word
Trinity is not in the Bible but the
concept of the Trinity is in the Bible
that's the point all right did Jesus say
that I'm three in one did Jesus say that
Jesus is not three in one so no he
wouldn't say that like well can you guys
believe that he's God yeah he says he's
God he's Son of God he's father and
spirit like what no we don't we don't
believe that Jesus is father and spirit
we believe he's the son we believe that
the father is the father we believe that
the spirit is the Holy Spirit we believe
that these three are one in essence well
is it written in the Bible yes it's
written all in the Bible that the son is
God that that the Son of God the father
is God is God so look so look uh Jay
this this is what I suggest okay and I
and you're welcome to come back anytime
but look up what the Trinity is and
Bible verses that like you know that um
where Christians pull from and then come
back to you like you guys are CRA for
like thinking like for believing in the
theory that's not been proven right and
go against like a like a book that's
never been proven wrong like at all okay
I I guess we can switch gears a little
bit but um why why do you think that the
Quran is true and why am I getting gifts
what do you mean because it's been
proven right multiple times okay I I
think it's been proven wrong multiple
times well can you show me proof yeah
for example the Quran the Quran says the
Quran says that Jesus said said that Aid
will come after him but Jesus never said
this there's nowhere in any text where
Jesus ever said these words what do you
mean Jesus did not write the book so
like obviously
huh you talking to me yeah you okay yeah
the Quran says that Jesus said words
that don't exist well how do you know it
doesn't exist because we have his words
in the Bible please please go down sit
down sit down you guys Believe In Like A
book that's been touched by humans
multiple times it's not the original
words of God the quran's been touched by
humans multiple times what are you
talking about that's not true oh who
wrote the Quran then well I'm not saying
it's not man-made I'm saying like it's
been it's been updated it's been updated
that's what I mean stop likeing in the
wrong way bro yeah yeah the Quran is
man-made and it's been updated
by literally literally you have in your
sources that the Quran was updated it
says it was Rewritten where are you
getting this information from ex-muslims
are read it no I'm getting it I'm
getting I'm getting it from the
ex-muslim bukari there's no such thing
as ex-muslims by the way oh but bukari
is an ex Muslim that's who I'm getting
it from also you guys believe like go
you guys follow John not Jesus go follow
Jesus not John okay I went I went to
ex-muslims blog and uh bukari was
writing in there and he brought up a
Hadith that he wrote about rewriting the
Quran you get information from R I got
can't be talking I got it from s bukari
ex Muslim blog no why don't you go and
read the Quran instead with an open mind
huh what what about bukari can I read
bukari even though he's the next movie
that's that's not true that's not true
that he was an ex-muslim he's just
talking he's a hateful Christian just
like you there's no such thing as a you
said bukari is a hateful Christian yep
father I like that bukari is a a hateful
Christian also you you guys believe in
me
likei that's why you guys are going
against us it's literally made up by you
guys you guys it's not true at allkar
bukari made all those Hadith huh where
are you getting this from I don't
understand like you just be bluffing and
stuff listen I don't know how old you
are but oh I'm mature like I'm more
mature than you that's for sure I I
agree you are yes you guys made the
Hadith you guys made it up that's 100%
relax relax relax like the hateful on
that's what I mean relax relax
relax okay you have you have to move
with patience and Grace okay you don't
want to don't don't let the Ops see your
next move man don't let them see you
bother all right you see the chat don't
let them see you bother them Ops
y'all that I'm more matur than like
90% of you guys here sh lower your Tong
that's right and and and and and Coptic
you better be quiet in the comment
section copti you ran that
well no cussing up here no cussing up
here all right all right yeah so look I
want you to do this okay in your spare
time just look up some of the things
that we talked about okay looked up
looked up bukari that is and um you'll
see why I laughed when you said he was a
faithful Christian okay and you go read
the Quran with an open mind and then
come and debate me all right I have read
the Quran with an open
mind I was open to its falsehood the
reason why I reject the Quran is cuz I
read it why are you lying I'm serious
why spreading misinformation what what
misinformation what the the
comments are so disrespectful G your
fans G your fans that's I got to
drop you now you're doing see when when
you when you begin to prove Muhammad
right that's when I have to drop you
when you prove that Muhammad was right
about something that's when I have to
drop you that's when I have to drop you
I can't allow you to be proven Muhammad
was right I can't what's that Hadith
guys y'all know what I'm talking about
about to read it and and it's
unfortunate I don't want this to be the
case but bro how how in the world am I
supposed to come against Muhammad if
he's right I'm trying to defend you guys
against him I'm trying to expose him but
you keep proving that he's right and I
don't know what to do man I just don't
know what to do how else can I expose
Muhammad but you guys keep Pro him
right let's let's read let's read we
just going to read
man I'm trying to I'm trying to I'm
trying to prove him to be a false
prophet but you guys are proving him
that he might be a real Prophet man I
I'm start I'm starting to see where mam
coming from I'm star I'm starting to
think that Muhammad was on or something
this is sah bukari the hateful Christian
this is the hateful Christian here's
bukari narrated Abu Ali once Allah's
messenger went out to the Musa or the
Alat prayer fter prayer then he passed
by the women and said oh women give arms
and I have seen that the majority of the
Dwellers of Hellfire were you women they
asked why is it so oh Allah's messenger
he
replied you curse frequently
come on
man this can't be the truth y'all keep
proving Muhammad right come on
man he
replied that the women are going to be
full of the Hellfire why cuz you curse
frequently isn't that what we were just
hearing from the sister wasn't you just
up here cursing up a storm and are
ungrateful to your husbands
I have not seen anyone more deficient in
intelligence and religion than you